on the throne zone  dave relatives read out the names of the  298 victims of flight mh17  this couple lost their son daughter and  four-year-old grandchild  and megan  it took over 20 minutes for all the  names of those who died to be read out  two-thirds of those who died were dutch  prime minister mark rutter expressed his  nation's sorrow  when death suddenly struck so massively  it hit everybody  together we are horrified together we  are angry  together we are silent  summer still  one candle for each of the 298 victims  this was a ceremony of remembrance  but for relatives of those who died it  does not provide closure almost four  months after the malaysian airliner was  shot down in ukraine human remains are  still being found at the crash site  coffins being repatriated  but no one has yet acknowledged  responsibility